numbers succeed in the east the terpenes
of Maryland out of the big 10 they will
play the winner of the first four games
[Music]
[Applause]
Congrats to UCF and el-hadji serene taco
job fall who is 7 feet 6 inches and one
of the 10 tallest living people in the
world we shot this before the tournament
so I assume my Knights have already
humiliated number 1 Duke and that
overhyped ion Williamson don't at me
March Madness is in full bloom like
watching the NBA if no one ever made a
shot not everyone loves exploiting
student athletes but everyone loves a
bracket so we created one for a region
that often gets overlooked despite
having over a trillion people it's the
far east video bracket no they
definitely got some sweet and sour
contenders like the number five seed
naked tablecloth guy
the man knows how to display his fine
china silky-smooth delightful of course
the number three seed wrench ninja
breezed through they call that move the
couching tiger
[Music]
facepunch boy is easily the strongest
number one seed in the field such a
tough competitor but the real
spinderella story is the number tendency
that shocked the world spinning water
monk this is passed down from the
Buddhist tradition of two sunny
that is what I am talking about such
grace such control over his or her body
oh you have got to be kidding me
like Virginia basketball he's consistent
but god damn it he's boring his stomach
just received total enlightenment nut
spoke too soon the spinning monk heat up
a prayer at the buzzer to win the
championship
give him his moment
[Music]
truly inspiring
you